this girl sees me she goes off she loses
her [__] mind so she saw me she was
like oh my god no kevin
oh no
oh no oh no
i can't believe this god must be playing
a trick on me
guy must be playing a trick on me oh my
god i said i was gonna see you once and
i see you and now i'm looking at you oh
my god i can't believe it oh my god
can you do me a favor can you wait here
for like 30 minutes my mom is about to
land she would love to get a picture
with you i was like
[__] y'all wait go ahead go get her as
soon as she left i took off [__] i'm
not standing here for another 30 minutes
waiting for your goddamn mom no kill
yourself die today
death to you [__] stop
i'm not [__] waiting for you my
daughter cursed for the first time the
other day i didn't get mad was watching
spongebob right something happened to
patrick out of nowhere she got mad she
was like [__]
i said wait what what'd you say she's
like [__] they got patrick dad you're
not watching
whoa all right
here's here's why i didn't get attitude
i'll tell you why i didn't get an
attitude okay
i didn't get attitude because i remember
my first time cussing my first time
cussing was because my mom smacked me in
front of company my friends was over my
house i'm downstairs we playing we
having a good time my mom come
downstairs she said hey i told you to
keep it down you don't run in this house
i do okay with that being said that's it
you're done go to bed
smack me
set me up to my room now you know when
you get smacked when you're a kid you
get hype when you get by yourself
you gonna smack me [__]
i was emotional i was an emotional ass
kid
i'm running away that's it
i packed the bag and everything you know
how many times i packed the bag with a
toy
i packed a bag with one toy i'm out i'm
sick of it
me and he-man are out
my mom gave my mom gave me permission to
cuss one time
one time she gave me permission to cuss
i'm in school i'm being bad my teacher
got mad said kevin kamir told me come to
the front of the class wrote a note
state with a note to my chest
said make sure your mother read the note
i get home my mom read the note the note
said maybe if you showed your son some
more attention at home he wouldn't act
like a fool in school right my mom read
the notes she said let me tell you
something you tell her
mind her damn business before i come
down there and i beat her ass
i thought okay do you want me to say it
like that or do you want me to take some
stuff out what i say tell her mind her
damn business before i come down there
and i beat her ass
i said i heard what you say i just want
to make sure that you know that you're
telling me to say the same thing
kevin if i tell you again i'm gonna
smack the [__] at you
okay now i got it okay i got it
okay i got it knocked i got it all right
i got it
keep in mind it's a lot of pressure all
right
my mom just gave me permission to go to
school and cuss my teacher out i didn't
feel comfortable the situation so i
wanted to practice i want to go upstairs
i want to go over my lines so
i'm in the mirror i'm going over my
lines i'm like okay all right okay all
right okay
my mom told me to tell you
to mind down now it's too loud that's
way too loud
that's not believable it's too loud
finally i go over it i get it down i'm
like you know what i'm gonna go to bed
early get some rest because i got a big
day ahead of me tomorrow i don't i don't
really mess this up
so i go to bed i wake up get dressed put
on my pants my shirt i get on the school
bus all my friends see me they get hyped
oh
canvas on the bus everybody look kev on
the bus what up kev i was like yo not
today y'all i got a lot of stuff in my
mind
i i can't really have y'all throwing me
off and my friend was like what you
talking about i can't really get into it
all i can tell y'all is that it's about
to go down
he's like what i said look man it's
about to go down just be behind me when
i walk in class he said all right cool i
walk in class miss green my teacher she
starts speaking everybody hello good
morning good morning hello hello good
morning she see me she was like kevin i
said miss green
she said this let your mother read the
note i said yes i did
she said well what did your mother say i
took a deep breath i looked at my
friends i was like it's about to go back
i said well uh
my mom told me to tell you
to mind your damn [__] business
[__]
little stupid [__]
little dumb teaching [__] two plus two
not knowing what the [__] it is [__]
cross side crying down your back fat
foot ass [__]
long kidding no nipple having ass [__]
the [__] that was crazy my friends was
in the background it was like oh
he said she ain't had no nipples
i got suspended i got suspended
and an ass with it my mom beat the [__]
out of me when i got home
i told you to say two cuss words
you said 76 of them
i thought i was samuel jackson i'm sick
and tired of these [__]
teachers at this [__] school i
had a trench coat on i flapped it
like you know when you flap it you got
to get that air under it [__] [__]
everybody in this [__] i don't give a
[__]
stupidest thing my dad ever did when he
was on drugs right when i was a kid i
remember my dad came to parent teacher
conference that's when you go to your
kid's school talk to your teacher see
how they do in the school my dad shows
up with sweatpants on with no draws
his [__] dick was all over the place
okay listen i cannot make this up let me
show y'all how my dad walked into my
school this is all i saw
[Applause]
every time he stops his debt kept moving
excuse me
i can't i can hear little girls like um
my dad got mad what the [__] is you
healing about you ain't never seen
nobody with a long dick hey dad don't
don't say that
you're gonna learn today
you're gonna learn what a long dick look
like today no dad
she don't need to learn that please
yeah my dad was crazy
my dad was really crazy man
see my dad was mad at me because i was
an athlete i didn't play sports i was in
a weird [__] like spelling bees debates
here's the thing my dad would show up in
my events and treat him as if they were
athletic events
first of all you can't cheer for no kid
in a spelling bee it's a spelling bee
it's quiet i'm focused i'm in the middle
of spelling a very difficult word my dad
shows up late bust through the back door
high as hell making cocaine noises all
right
once again i cannot make this up all
right this this is all i heard i'm in
the middle of spelling some [__] out of
nowhere all i heard was all right all
right all right
[Applause]
yeah
my son's spelling the [__] out these
[__] words
and your face [__] and your face all
right all right all right
[__] made me laugh the most you see here
y'all sitting next to people i told you
my dad never wore draws ever
[Applause]
this is my dad getting to a seat this is
all i saw excuse me
[Music]
i can hear people like oh god jesus ah
what is it i don't know i don't know
what it is whatever it is is loose it's
all over the place
it's got to be a penis i don't know what
else it could be my dad got mad there
ain't no penis that's a long dick hey
dad
don't say that all right all right all
right
you gonna learn today
you'll learn what a long dick look like
today
hey son let me hear you spell a long
dick no dad i can't it's against the
rules
oh
dear no dad
all right all right all right
this [__] had the dog with him
not dad the dog is on drugs too dad
please
my goal is at the end of the show is to
have y'all saying that [__] for no
reason at all
for no reason at all
next time your ladies say something to
you just cut her off it don't matter
what you say hey babe shut up [__] all
right all right all right
gotta make you suck on this long dick
you're gonna learn today
all right all right all right
i wish i could be a rapper or some [__]
i really do
you know why i can't be a rapper don't
man cause my voice ain't deep enough to
be a rapper you need a deep voice that's
the only way people want to listen to
you on a regular basis i don't think
nobody would buy my album because my
voice is too small
yeah [__] i'm a killer i'll shoot you
in your face
sure i'm sharing everybody going down
sure i'm sure every
body gonna die tonight
did he just say home [__]
i'm not buying that [__] if he says
certain [__] just keeps you from being
tough you won't know what's really
keeping me from being tough look at this
this is really holding me back look at
this [__] here look at this
look at this [__] look at this [__]
this is really [__] me up man
there ain't nothing tough about this it
don't matter what you say ain't nobody
gonna take you serious if you swing your
feet it don't matter i will kill
everybody in this [__] tonight
[__] playing with y'all y'all think
it's a game
no i'm sick of it i'm sick of the way
people treat me around here
would you talk to a guy who swung his
feet
if you had a club and i tried to talk to
you come on babe let me hold you for a
second you girl you know damn well who
i'm talking to wait a second let me
climb down and get my feet together wait
a minute now
rappers make me laugh though i swear
rappers are funny man you ever see
rappers freestyle like when they be
battling each other you ever notice the
more angry rapper get the higher his
hands get you everyone knows that
[Laughter]
they start off so calm like
this is rappers when they freestyle you
like to do just to do when he be
listening to the other guy
you ready no i got him i got him
wait this is really how they big look
real talk
look
hey
i'm really trying to be a rapper right
now
like this
this
this is the real angry rapper
real talk
i kill [__] i say [__] that don't
love it [__] you want to beat me to get
it i give it back
how's the dude
[__] this thing is crazy
he'll be trying to follow his hands it's
like he's crazy he's about to kill me
see i've seen a woman get here it's
unattractive the reason why it's
unattractive is because when a woman
reaches a certain level of crazy she
doesn't know
that she's being crazy everybody else
knows everybody else sees it hey that
[__] in the corner with the diaper on
her face is [__] crazy yo she's
[__] crazy she's a psychopath
everybody else knows except her here's
the thing i was in that situation i saw
a woman get crazy let me see how i knew
this one chick went wild okay we in the
house one day arguing all [__] day
gets to the point i'm like you know what
i can't argue with you no more my head
hurts i'm done i'm getting the shower
i'm getting dressed i'm going to the
store true story people that's exactly
what i do getting showered get dressed
get my car start driving to the store on
the way to the store i hit a speed bump
when i hit the speed bump i hear a lot
of noise in the trunk
boom
that's weird i ain't put [__] in the
trunk the [__] is all that noise in a
goddamn trunk i'm small i get scared
fast so i get out the car i pop the
truck did some true [__] i popped the
trunk when i popped the trunk this [__]
was stooped down in a trunk like this
looking at me
i see her in the goddamn trunk i see her
see me see her in the goddamn trunk i
just caught you in the trunk of my car
you gotta say something to justify what
the [__] i'm looking at the [__] are you
doing in the goddamn trunk with a
straight face she looks at me jumps out
the trunk rolls her eyes and takes off
as if i never saw her
[Applause]
now let me tell you why i had an
attitude i had an attitude because we
live together like i'm going to see you
tonight
we have to address this at some point in
time i said no [__] that we're gonna
talk about this right now i get in the
car i drive home here's where it gets
crazier when i get home she in the
kitchen cooking right
i walk in the house she said hey babe
you hungry [__] what the
oh
what
how much i don't got that food i want to
talk about why i popped the trunk and
you popped out the goddamn trunk like
goddamn jack in the box the [__] were
you doing in the goddamn trunk with a
straight face she looked at me she said
i wasn't in no goddamn trunk
[__] i saw you see me see you
in the goddamn trunk you ain't see me no
goddamn trunk you must have started them
other [__] you be [__] with
goddamn truck
yeah yeah
it messed me up so bad i started
thinking i was like
did i have another [__] in the trunk i
made him
oh no i might have put another [__] in
the trunk and forgot she was in this
room
what else do i like i don't like
ostriches i'm scared of ostriches
for those people don't know what an
ostrich is it's a big ass bird that's
the same size as me these birds are huge
okay i'm in nebraska doing a show in
nebraska i had to pee so i'm on the side
of the road i'm peeing right i get done
peeing i look to my left it's a big ass
ostrich looking at me while i'm peeing
he was standing on one leg like this
his body was facing this way but his
head his head was like this
now i didn't know what it was so i
didn't say anything
my friend got the car he's like yo
what's that i don't know it's like a big
ass man pigeon i don't know
i don't know what it is right
he's like there ain't no man pigeon i
was like it is a man pigeon he took a
pin he threw an ink panetta right as
soon as he did pin at it hit the ostrich
in the chest as soon as he hit the
ostrich his other leg came down his body
was still facing this way but his head
was him still like this
now
when his leg came down this is when the
[__] started to come out of me a little
bit
i was like you know what we should um
we should we should probably go get back
in the car because
because we don't really know what that
means you know what i mean like that
that that could be a sign that can mean
like you got 10 seconds to get the [__]
out my face
before i kill you i'm gonna eat your
kids we don't we don't know what he's
trying to say so let's just get back in
the car we say that so we get in the car
as soon as we get in the car and start
laughing i'm like ah
you're a [__] man like no you're a
[__] i don't know you're a [__] i'm
laughing i'm driving like 30 miles per
hour i look out the passenger window the
ostrich was running 30 miles per hour
inside the car his body was still facing
this way
but his head was still like this
he was hard ass
at 30 miles per hour now when i'm scared
like if i'm real real scared i get
emotional i'll start to cry if i'm real
real scared so i got a little emotional
you know i looked at my friend
i was like
why would you
why would you throw a pin at it
if
if if we if we don't even know
what it is
no no no i'm not saying that i'm saying
like i'm saying we don't even know what
it is
he's like dude stop bitching speed up
speed up i lied to y'all now i started
driving like 60 miles per hour when i
tell y'all that this ostrich was running
60 miles per hour i'm not bullshitting
his body was still facing this way
but his head was still like this he was
running something you couldn't even see
his legs he was going so [__] fast
he was moving and the reason why i was
so scared is because he never looked in
front of him like he didn't care about a
wall
another ostrich he was just looking at
us but the way he was looking at us is
like he was saying when i catch y'all
i'ma [__] both y'all up
over a pen
over a goddamn pen
and i was like why don't you just
apologize you know what i'm saying like
because i didn't throw the pen i was
scared that's the only time i've been
[__] on myself in my life i've never
shielded myself but i let go that time i
let loose
i really did because i had i had to go
now my job is to make you all laugh and
educate at the same time
here's my goal to educate see a lot of
couples here on double dates tonight
okay
i'll tell you why you don't do that
tell you why shaq i'm out of here
listen to this [__] some real [__]
[__] [__] with you know you for a minute
pay attention okay i'm small but i
[__] know a lot of [__]
okay
here's why you don't double date and pay
attention it's serious all you do is
compete with the other couple that's it
i'm telling you real [__] let's say he
lean over give her a kiss love you babe
it's innocent love you babe first thing
she gonna do she gonna look at you she's
like must be nice
now
now the competition started now the only
way you can win is the sucker titty at
the table that's it now listen
what i'm saying is real okay
no
here's
here's my point
here's my [__] boy
why'd she cover her titties
like he was going to jump on the titties
all right no he's not it's just i'm just
talking shelly listen
here's the [__] up thing okay here's
why i say that women are so emotional
they discuss everything shaq they
[__] talk they talk about your
business men y'all don't discuss each
other business all we talk about is the
[__] that we might do that's it but they
discuss everything and it come out all
night like this are y'all out y'all
drinking it's all-star weekend you're
having a good time this one and [__]
come out i'ma show you how i come out
you get mad at her you're like you know
what keisha i can't stand when you come
out you get drunk you [__] tonight
she's like whatever dying at least i
don't eat ass you like what
listen
everybody was talking i didn't know
it would come out
now now you got to sit there with a u8
ass face
he's sitting there like this
that's that's the you ain't ass face
right so of course you bring it back up
because you mad you're like hey look
first of all only time i ate your ass
was on your birthday no no
no no [__] it you want to talk about it
let's talk about it i didn't get you
[__] so i ate your ass don't make it
seem like i'm out here every day and i'm
just eating your ass everybody's sitting
here pushing my glass to the side like i
got the [__] mouth [__] y'all better
won't be no more ass eating over here
i'm kevin hart i love y'all i swear to
god
explain why if you're my best friend i
shouldn't have to ask you to lie for me
i shouldn't have to ask your permission
for me to put you in my lot you know why
cause you're my best [__] friend
[__] that's your job the day that we
sign up and say that we best friends
that means that my [__] is your
[__] and your [__] it's my
[__]
if you're my real best friend you should
know that i need you to lie for me by
the look on my face if i'm looking at
you and i'm not blinking if i'm like
this
that's a goddamn sign that means [__]
got to drop on us my back is against the
wall this is not a test it's the real
deal
help me
[__]
[Applause]
my friend harry
ignored all signs okay
let me tell you i should hit the fan i'm
telling you i should hit the fan i come
in the house right come in the house
it's like four in the morning i'm drunk
people drunk as [__] i have no balance
i'm all over the place i'm rocking back
forth as soon as i walk in the house she
wakes up she goes off you know what i'm
sick of this i know he's probably out
with some [__] you just probably
messing with some [__] now i'm drunk i
don't want to respond cause i don't have
any balance i'm rocking back and forth
you don't look believable when you're
rocking back and forth so i had to
choose a stance in which i looked
believable so i chose this i said let me
tell you something listen to me
run nobody with no [__] okay you're
wrong matter of fact to prove you wrong
i'ma call harry harry not expecting me
to call right now so harry don't have no
reason to lie and i'm gonna put it on
speakerphone about to make you feel
stupid watch this watch how [__]
stupid you feel
watch
watch this
harry
real quick don't lie
let's stop right there let's just stop
right there for a second what what does
that mean what does that mean people
lie
it means lie right now i mean the [__]
got to drop on us my back is against the
wall this is not a test it's the real
deal
help me
help
me
[__]
help me
harry ignored all sides
i'm telling you exactly what harry said
i said harry harry real quick don't lie
where we coming from right now he said
man
you was with that [__] with the fat ass
what
oh no
no no no no no no no
oh no no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
people understand something i'm not i'm
not mad at harry the reason i'm not mad
at harry is because harry has done some
dumb [__] but i understand who he is see
harry might be the smartest dumbest
friends i've ever had in my life okay
let me tell you the dumbest thing that
harry's ever done
harry invented the code for us to use to
let each other know when we were around
our women basically if somebody used a
code means don't say anything stupid you
might be on speakerphone don't say
nothing dumb the phone might be loud
enough so my girl can hear whatever it's
just saying it means don't say anything
that could jeopardize our relationship
the code was
man i'm hungry as [__] that's cold
people
man
i'm hungry as [__]
here's what pissed me off about the code
harry
invented the [__] code
so there's no reason why harry should
have messed up the code here's how he
messes it up i'm in the car my lady i'm
driving stay in the passenger seat harry
calls me when i'm in the car i got the
bluetooth [__] in the car so my phone
rings the whole car rings harry's name
pops up on the dashboard i answer what
up boy kev was going on ain't [__] this
i knew the conversation was about take
turns for the worst cause i knew it was
about to get filthy he said
[__]
[Applause]
hey
man i'm hungry as [__]
he said i'm not i
[Applause]
i said man i'm hungry as [__] he said yo
you should go to subway get the footlong
fight out
[Applause]
i said man i'm hungry as [__] he said oh
that must mean you ready to eat these
white [__]
what oh no
no no no no no no no
no no no i ain't need no white [__] i
ain't no white [__] i never did
oh my god no
oh no
[__] kill y'all man get fired on
these [__] again
i'm scared of dolphins as well
i'm very scared of dolphins and i like i
said i got a reason to be scared of
everything i'm afraid of right me and my
lady went maui one time when maui she's
like babe we should go swim with the
dolphins i'm like no i told you how i
feel about them dolphins i don't want to
swim in the dark she's like come on stop
acting like that let's swim to dolphins
i was like you know what let's run the
dolphin something happened to me it's
going to be on your conscience now we go
to swim the dolphins they got the
dolphins in like this little tank right
it's like eight dolphins i see an old
lady on the back of a dolphin these
little boys i'm like you know what babe
i might have been overreacting get the
camera take some pictures of me on back
of the dolphin i was excited right i get
in the water i'm on back of the dolphin
the instructor he says soon as you grab
the dolphin finn the dolphin gonna start
taking you around so whenever you ready
grab his fin as soon as i grab my
dolphin fin my dolphin went straight to
the bottom of the tank he went straight
down right
now because i was scared i didn't let go
i held on and you know when you scared
you start to mentally create stuff in
your own mind i was like it's obvious
that i got a racist dolphin he don't
like black people that's obvious he
didn't cut a deal with a shark to bring
him a black piece of meat something bad
about to happen right
i let go i get to the top i start
snapping on the instructor i was like
nobody just saw dolphin number eight
missing huh nobody noticed that i was
going for like 30 seconds you don't have
a bell or nothing that you ring he tried
to kill me he took me to the bottom of
the tank to meet with sharks okay i'm
the only black dot in this damn tank you
didn't notice that i wasn't going around
huh you see this old lady and this
little boy but nobody noticed the black
swirl missing nobody noticed it and he
was like whoa whoa calm down it's three
feet just stand up and i was like what
what'd he say
i didn't even realize that i was walking
and talking at the same time
but it was a racist dolphin i'm gonna
tell you how i know it was racist
dolphin because like you know how dolph
is like
well when i got out the water i looked
at him and he looked at me he's like
[__] [__] i said what did you just
what
let me tell you the worst person my
family the worst person in my family is
my cousin al i tell you why my cousin i
was on drugs too but unlike my dad al
found jesus see but i was one of those
people that found jesus and now that he
found jesus he tries to throw jesus on
everybody you meet somebody like that
for no reason all they thought religion
at you you did nothing to deserve this
conversation no matter what you say they
bring up religion hey good morning now
uh it is a good morning because jesus
woke us up hello boom i love him do you
what
the [__] does that have to do with
anything man
i'm trying to play basketball this ain't
got [__] to do with nothing
oh
i got mad at me because i live in l.a
he said kevin you out here in hollywood
doing god knows what
sex
drugs
money
lord knows what you're into need to get
a relationship with god i said don't
talk to me about god i'm fine okay you
don't want us on drugs you get a
relationship with god he got mad now
anytime he get mad he already got to
bring up some dark [__] from his past
that nobody needs to know i don't know
where he said kevin let me tell you
something i know i was on drugs but i
found jesus granted i didn't know him
when i was out there sucking dick for
money but i'll tell you something i said
wait a minute wait wait a minute
hold wait first of all you're not gonna
speed past that like you didn't just say
what you just said
i said what was this what year was this
he said he said it was in the 80s
everybody was doing it this is [__] to
piss me off he said your dad was back
there with me i said what
my dad was like all right all right all
right
hey you gonna learn today uh no the [__]
i'm not
yo keep that lesson to yourself
i told my dad to go get one cup and put
your name on it that is your cup
they're gonna drink out another goddamn
glass in this house that's it for you
[Music]
[Applause]
then it dawned on me where she got it
from because i met her dad earlier that
day her dad had one of those laughs i
called the rich white guy laugh you know
that is it's a laugh that's followed by
an awful joke the joke doesn't make you
laugh but the laugh eventually makes you
laugh he found out i was a comedian he
kept trying to tell me jokes he's like
oh
so uh
so you're a comic right
okay
um
ah
all right all right all right listen i
gotta um i got a joke for you you can
you can keep it if you want i don't mind
um
all right all right all right you ready
all right okay
all right this is crazy it's so good all
right
so i'm at i'm at the office i'm at the
office i tell this guy i said to him
what did i wait what did i say wait a
minute
all right
all right so i'm at the office right i'm
at the office and uh i tell this guy
i said to him i said hey uh pass me the
stapler but when you pass it make sure
stables are in it because if it isn't i
can't staple anything
i didn't want to laugh but he kept
looking right at me
while he was doing it
here's a weird thing you're like you
know how people clap when they laugh
[Music]
he had a clap that he would do with his
laugh but i never knew when it was
coming i couldn't time it
now you know how sometimes you can time
and clap i didn't know when the clap was
coming so it was hard for me to
participate and clap with him because it
took too long right but he was still
looking at me the whole time he was like
uh
that's like 57 seconds right there i
can't wait 57 seconds
it's a long time ago
i'm just being honest
now ladies i know what you think you
like kevin you don't like all this stuff
about us i'm quite sure some stuff that
we don't like about you you're
absolutely right i'll tell you what you
don't like about me i don't have sex for
very long
i'm not playing you got about a good 20
to 23 seconds with me ladies and i'm
very serious
i'm serious here's the thing i don't
care i come quick whatever it is what it
is fellas if you come fast embrace it be
good in that amount of time all you got
to do is disguise it put a girl in a lot
of positions that's what i do i push in
like nine positions in 23 seconds i'm
not playing
you don't believe me okay all right
watch this i'ma [__] the [__] out this
stool for 23 seconds you brought this on
yourself don't make me laugh this is
serious [__]
shut the [__] up you about to get it go
[Applause]
you all right
you want some juice
that's how you know when you ain't doing
[__] when you want some
when a man asks you do you want some
juice he knows his dick wasn't [__] you
want some juice
i'll go in the kitchen i'll get some
juice she wasn't a jew
you got me to make you some juice i can
make you some juice from scratch
hey
fellas y'all get that hump in your back
you know what that is y'all get that
turtle shell so you come too hard
that [__] right there
that turtle shell your head go in and
out the shell
[__]
just caught a charlie horse in my back